how to convince a customer to buy from
you first of all I don't think you need
to convince customers to buy from you
the biggest challenge here for
entrepreneurs is you don't stand for
something there's nothing unique or
different about you that makes customers
want to work with you if you're the same
as everybody else with the same product
same service same features as everybody
else is nothing unique about you then
you've stuck in the trap of having to
try too hard sell people and follow up
when you get desperate and you cut your
prices and you don't get the business
that you want you don't get the clients
that you want you don't get the repeat
customers that you want the key thing
that separates great entrepreneurs from
the mediocre ones is that they stand for
something there's something that they
believe in they're trying to change the
world for the better there's something
that makes you want to work with them so
you have to first figure out what that
is for your business you want to create
something that will make you a magnet
for ideal customers in my business for
example I'm all about belief right that
comes across in every video my website
Facebook everything I believe in
entrepreneurs I believe that you have to
do the right thing I believe that you
have to find something that you're
passionate about I believe that you can
make it if you keep trying I believe
that things will work out even if you
don't know how they're gonna work out
but they will worked out for you if you
keep going and you're on the right path
I believe in entrepreneurs and that's
powerful and that gets people excited
and you see people sharing hashtag
believe and you see them believing in
themselves more and spreading the
content and spreading my message because
they make it their message what's your
message what's unique about your company
why should I buy from you why should I
care everything is so mediocre in this
world there's very little that separates
one company from another and so you're
not giving customers a reason to buy
from you and it shouldn't have to be
them coming in and your heart selling
them and you're following up with them
constantly beating them down until they
get so frustrated with you or you give
them such a low price that that's the
only way you're gonna stand out you
want to compete on price price is the
worst way to stand out it's not a
long-term sustainable advantage you need
something else if you want to convince
customers to buy from you you want them
to line up to buy from you and tell
their friends you have to make them feel
something what are they gonna feel about
your business this could be anything
think about the best companies in the
world the biggest brands think about
Nike right think about Nike they sell
shoes they sell a commodity but you feel
something when you're buying Nike
because Nike they will honor great
athletes and you feel when you see their
ads for Michael Jordan or LeBron James
or whoever it is you feel connected to
them you feel like when you're putting
on their shoes you are trying to be a
great athlete you're gonna push yourself
to be the best that's a feeling you get
from a pair of shoes from a commodity
item what do you want your customers to
feel and that comes from you that comes
from your heart that comes from a place
of supreme importance that comes from a
place where other people can't replicate
it because nobody else can be you so
what is it what's your feeling what do
you want customers to feel when they
work with you a great example that I
gave a while back on a video was I had a
reader write in and he wants to start a
flower shop and he said he likes flowers
because it makes him feel calm so that's
a great angle how many flower shops are
there there's tons of flower shops how
do you stand out you're the only one
who's all about calm so you have to have
a calm exterior right you need calm
signage you need the flowers that make
you calm and make people feel calm the
music coming into your place should be
calm your staff should be calm
everything that you believe in
everything that you put out there has to
be about calm that's how you stand out
that's how you make a difference and now
you're not convincing customers to buy
any more because people who come are
going to be the ones who want to feel
calm with flowers you're not selling
flowers you're selling calm so what are
you selling in your business that's not
your product or service you have to be
selling in emotion so now this guy who's
setting up this calm flower shop he's
gonna get people who come to him who
want to feel calm and they're gonna tell
their friends who also want to feel
he's building momentum he's creating a
magnet for calm people and he wants to
be calm so these are ideal clients for
him you don't want people coming to you
who are rushed and stressed out and who
just needs something for Valentine's Day
those aren't your customers and you
don't want to be hammering over who has
the best last minute Valentine's Day
special you want to be able to charge
your premium you want to be able to
charge you more and you want to work
with ideal customers who believe the
same thing is you and that comes from
making them feel something so when I'm
working with clients I don't create huge
proposals and pitches I don't follow up
with them and try to hard sell them I
make them feel something they're coming
to me for a reason
and I make them feel connected to
believe and if they don't believe then I
don't want to work with them it wouldn't
be a good fit anyway and if they do then
they will love to work with me and I'll
give them great results so you got to
figure out what that is for your
business
I got into an argument the other day
with my agent who wanted me to follow up
on a company that wanted to work with me
I don't follow up with companies and
it's not out of a ego thing
I don't follow up with companies because
if they don't want to work with me
that's fine I don't want to work with
them
I want companies who get what I do
because I put out a powerful message and
it attracts companies and those who want
to work with me they do and we make
great deals together and those who don't
I'm not gonna follow up with because the
guys you have to follow up with over and
over and over and over again they're not
gonna be great customers right the guys
are on the fence who don't really
believe in what you're doing who are
considering all these other options
they're not gonna be great long-term
customers we're gonna buy more from you
and pass on their friends to you you're
gonna spend all this time chasing these
bad leads for what instead invest your
time into creating a powerful message
that will make people make ideal clients
come and find you this is all in
response to a question that came back
from one of my newsletter readers
Raymond Raymond is in the sound hiring
comfortab isness he's basically selling
up microphone speakers DJ equipment
and what he says is he sucks on creating
proposals and convincing customers to
buy from him and he ends up just
competing on price and they feel that
he's desperate because that's what
you're putting out there Raymond that's
what you're putting out that you're
desperate why should people hire you
what is unique about your business you
are not in the business of renting out
sound and DJ equipment that's not what
you're doing what emotion are you
tapping into that's what you're selling
and then everything that comes from that
has to flow from that top emotion in my
business everything is about belief if I
did something that was not believe it'd
be inconsistent people wouldn't tweak to
it they wouldn't like it but that's
impossible because I'm all III am
believe I believe in I want to see you
be successful I believe in you
what's your emotion what are you trying
to put out there that every single
message that you create has to be tied
to that so your ideal customers who also
believe in the same thing will find and
so Raymond you are not selling or
renting out DJ equipment you're renting
out and you're selling something totally
different that emotion something that
comes from you something that no other
DJ rental business can compete with you
got to find it you got to find out what
that is something powerful something
that is to your core something that you
believe in something that is regardless
of your business any business that
you're in
you're gonna bring this with you right
that flower guy who loves calm if he
wasn't starting the flower shop he'd
start something else that was still
around calm if I wasn't believing in
entrepreneurs I'd start something else
that's but it's still belief because
that's core to me and it's core to my
audience and people want to believe in
something you just got to give them a
reason and when you create something
powerful something emotional something
that gets people excited doesn't that
draws people in then you don't have to
convince them about anything they want
to work with you you're the only one
talking about this stuff in your space
the world is filled with mediocre
businesses almost nobody does a good job
your competition the people who are
number one in your field are just
slightly above average you have a
massive opportunity to stand out by
creating the powerful emotion that ties
people to your business and if you do
that you'll have more fun because you're
doing something that you powerfully
believe in you're gonna make more money
you're gonna work with ideal clients and
you're gonna have an ability to really
impact your community and maybe the
world so find that emotion and put it to
use and you won't have to convince
customers to buy from you anymore
believe for those of you watching like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below it always makes you want to do
more for you and I'd love to hear what
you have to think you have a problem
with your business or you like this
video leave a comment underneath let me
know you have a question I'm a good
video response thank you so much and
I'll see you soon
[Music]